what happened what got to this point is  that  how  australia would have typically chosen to  handle a crisis like covet a pandemic  like covet or did politics heavily get  involved in the last couple years it's a  really good question i've done a lot of  thinking about it jordan peterson asked  me on his show the same question and  i sort of  reverted to form a little bit i suppose  and sort of thought the training when  we're in politics is be careful what you  say about your own country outside it no  it wasn't quite tough enough  the reality in australia was as i  mentioned as a federation  what you saw internationally more than  anything else was the city of melbourne  in the state of victoria which is led by  a pretty far left socialist premier  um yeah it was bad and it's still going  on because they arrested and handcuffed  a pregnant lady  for you know doing the wrong thing